اهلا بكم مجددا الى بانوراما في سوريا نفت
وسائل اعلام محليه صحه التقارير الاعلاميه
التي تحدثت عن عزم الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي زياره دمشق كانت تحدثت
مصادر اعلاميه خارجيه عن زياره للرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي الى دمشق خلال
الايام المقبله مضيفه ان ايران قدمت دعما
اقتصاديا وماليا تجاوز ال 20 مليار دولار
كما قدمت الميليشيات والاسلحه والدعم
العسكريه لانقاذ النظام وهي تريد ثمنا
لذلك من الحليف المصادر افادت ان ايران
تريد موضوعا عسكريا استراتيجيا يعزز
موقعها في المنطقه وتريد منطقه قدم
استراتيجي على البحر المتوسط كما تريد
تنازلات سياديه ماليه في حقول النفط
والغاز والفوسفات والمشاريع والاتصالات
اخر الطلبات انها تريد ان يعامل
الايرانيون معامله خاصه مقارنه بالسوريين
يسكن انه في عام يعني 21 قال مصدر ايراني
في دمشق انه يتوقع ان تكون سوريا اول محطه
خارجيه للرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي الا
ان تلك الزياره لم تحدث حينها
من دمشق ينضم الينا عبر سكايب عمر رحمون
المتحدث باسم المصالحه السوريه ومعنى من
امستردام عبر سكايب يعقوب سعيد الباحث في
الشان الايراني وابدا مع ضيفي من دمشق سيد
عمرو سؤال يتعلق بهذه الزياره لماذا لم
تتم ومتى يمكن ان تتم
تحيه لك ولسان المشاهدين سيدتي الكريمه
يعني كل ما تم نشره الان او هي عباره عن
وسائل الاعلام نشرت هذه الشائعه ووسائل
اعلام محليه رده ورفت هذه صحه هذه الشائعه
يعني المشكله انه لا يوجد هناك خبر رسمي
يؤكد بان هناك زياره للرئيس الايراني
الرئيسي يوم الثلاثاء كما كما هو معروف في
هذا الجميع بان هذا الامر لم يتم
هذا واذا كانت هذه المعلومات اشاعه وانا
اضفت لسؤال لسؤال متى ستتم هذه الزياره
لانه وكاله فاس الايرانيه نفسها ب 20 21
كانت قد تحدثت عن ان الوجه الاولى للرئيس
الايراني ستكون سوريا لماذا لم تحدث حتى
هذه اللحظه
انا اضيف لك بان السفير السوري في ايران
هو اول من تحدث وقال بان هناك رئيس
يمكن ان نبني على تصريح السفير السوري بان
هناك زياره للرئيس الايراني الى سوريا لكن
لم يتم تحديد موعد هذه الزياره وبالتالي
يعني البث الشائعات بان هناك زياره ثم تم
الغاء هذه الزياره وبانه هناك طلبات
ايرانيه تتعلق بالسياده السوريه وهنا وهذا
كلام في الحقيقه كله يعني شائعات وليس له
اصل الصحه علاقه بثينه بين سوريا وايران
لا يمكن لهذه الشائعات او الدعايات او
الكلام الاعلامي ان يؤثر على مكانه هذه
العلاقه بين سوريا وايران هناك محور
مقاومه يبدا من ايران ينتهي به فلسطين
وسوريا هي حجر الاساس في هذا المحور لا
يمكن لهذا التصريح او اذا يعني ايران
والانفتاح الان ان كان سوريا على همم
تركيا او على الدول العربيه ولكن اسمح لي
ان اتحدث عن الزياره نفسها بصوره عامه مع
ضيفي من امستردام سيد يعقوب همم لماذا حتى
الان لم نرى الرئيس الايراني في سوريا رغم
كل ما قيل في السابق وما يسار الان وذكر
ضيفنا على انه اشعاعات لماذا لا نراه في
سوريا
حتى المركز الثقافي الايراني في دمشق دعا
بان همم ازمه المحروقات في طريقه الانفراج
وذلك خلال الازمه خلال زياره متوقعه علي
ابراهيم رئيس في سوريا او اقل خلال 48
ساعه يعني همم هذا الحديث كان يوم الاثنين
او يوم الاحد بمعنى كان كان زياره من
المتوقع حدوته وليست
اعلاميه فقط ما في ما يتعلق بعدم زياره
فممكن اعادتها الى هذه الازمه الصامته
التي همم بين سوريا وايران هي تصورها هي
الاسواق بين البلدين ممكن العدسه نعود
بالوقت الى الوراء بعد الزياره
الى سوريا في همم قبل اشهر
وطلب من النظام الايراني
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم برميل بالفعل
في الحقيقه لم تنطلق الى الى سوريا
وكذلك النظام السوري
الخارجيه على لسان سفيره في هناك فتصور
بينما
يشهد من سوريا اكبر ازمه اقتصاديه على
مستوى المحروقات في من في المناطق التي
تخضع لسيطره يحاول النظام الايراني
استخدام هذه الازمه ان يكون يعني ثمن هذا
النقطه الايراني
يعني انتزاع اخر ما تبقى من الصفات
السياديه
نشر او تم تسريبه من انه اتفاقيه ايران
تريد توقيعها وبالتالي اعود للسيد عمر حول
هذه الميقات كان في وعود ايرانيه دعم همم
سوريا بالنفط ولم تحدث بالفعل لماذا اذا
دعنا نقول انه همم قضيه الاتفاق هو مجرد
شائعات قضيه الزياره مجرد شائعات اين هو
النفط
يا سيدتي الكريمه يعني بالنسبه لموضوع
التنسيق السوري الايراني الاقتصادي ايران
تقدمت كل ما لديها لاجل سوريا وليس الان
قدمت الدماء وقدمت الشهداء وقدمت النفط
ووقفت الى جانب سوريا لايران مصلحه كبرى
في بقاء الدوله السوريه في الحفاظ على هذه
الدوله كما هي هذا وهي المسلحه الاولى
الايراني اما لماذا لم يصل النفط يعني
ايران كما تعلمون وكمال العالم ايران انت
فاضي على العقوبات غربيه اوروبيه امريكيه
وكذلك سوريا وكذلك روسيا فالموضوع عائد
الى موضوع العقوبات ثم اسرائيل وامريكا
تلاحق كل حاملات النفط يعني الحامل
الاخيره كانت محتزله في اليونان وقبلها
حامل احتجت في قبرص فالموضوع له علاقه
بالعقبات ومنع هذه الحاملات من الوصول الى
سوريا اما انه ايران تريد ان تقبض ثمن
ايران المصلحه الكبرى الايرانيه في سوريا
هي بقاء وعندما وقف العالم كله او معظمه
ضد سوريا لاسقاط الدوله السوريه وقفت
ايران وروسيا والصين وقدمت ايران الشهداء
والدماء والمال والنفط حتى لا ينصحوا هذا
لا يمكن لنا ان
نتغاضى عن ما قيل من انه هناك تسلل ايراني
الى النسيج المجتمعي الاقتصادي همم السوري
في الداخل السوري وبالتالي ما يطرح الان
حتى فيما يتعلق بال التعاطي مع الايراني
وكانه سوري ربما هو مطبق على الارض بطريقه
غير مباشره بحسب ما يقول المراقبين ان
انتقل الى السيد يعقوب الحديث عن همم غياب
همم او تاجيل او ربما اا عدم هذه تنفيذ
هذه الزياره اذا ما صح التعبير سؤال هو
انت تقول بانه سوريا منبعده من ايران لانه
البعض يقول انه لا العكس ربما يكون الواقع
ايران هي المنطقه من سوريا خاصه في تتعلق
بانفتاحها ربما على الدول العربيه ايضا
فتح الاوراق مع تركيا ربما
اعلق على الحديث العقوبات يعني ايران وفقا
للمسؤولين الايرانيين والصحف الايرانيه
والصحف الدوليه تصدر النفط الى الى الصين
عبر شركات حلقتها في الشرق في الشرق
الاوسط وفي كذلك في اسيا وفي روسيا فانا
تساءل هنا هل الصين اقرب ام سوريا يعني
اذا هي المساله عائده للعقبات كيف تستطيع
ايران ان تصدر الى الصين ولا تستطيع ان
تصدر سوريا عدم
الذهاب هذه السفن الى سوريا هو همم ليس
العائد الى الى العقوبات بل هو عائد الى
ازمه حقيقيه ازمه صامته بين الدولتين لا
يمكن هذا الطرف عن هذا الجانب تصور
الامتعاض
كما هو من الطرفين يعني لا يمكن لانه ليس
انتعاش سوري تجاه ايران او امتعاد ايراني
اتجاه سوريا ومن الطرفين عائد الى عدم
تحقيق سوريا لبعض من الاتفاقيات التي وقعت
في عام 2017 مع سوريا مثلا همم سوريين او
النظام السوري سرع بالاتفاقيات التي وقعت
مع الجانب الروسي بينما لم يسرع بهذه
الاتفاقيه التي وقعت همم مع الجانب
الايراني ما عدا شركه الاتصالات التي تحدث
الاعلام عنها في الفتره الاخيره ايضا من
الجانب الاخر الايرانيين
بهذه السفن والمحروقات بظل هذه الحاجه
القويه السوريه لهذه المحروقات اليوم يعني
استطاع النظام
الايراني ان يرسل الكثير من الشاحنات الى
لبنان مثلا ولكن لم يرسلها الى ذلك انا
اتصور هي المشكله الحقيقيه
حول هذه العلاقه دعنا ننتقل للسيد عمر
يبدو ان العلاقه ليست سويه
هذا الكلام قيل في الاعلام خلال للعشر
سنوات الماضيه وخل- خلال 20 سنه ماضيه و30
سنه ماضيه ثم بعد ذلك الوقائع تؤكد بان
العلاقه السوريه الايرانيه هي علاقه متينه
ولا يمكن لكل ما يقال ولكل هذه الشائعات
ان تؤثر قدر شعره على هذه العلاقه ربما
تكون يعني هناك اسباب كثيره اولها الحصار
والعقوبات الاوروبيه والغربيه على ايران
وسوريا ربما ثانيها يعني انشغال ايران
ببعض الاحداث في الداخل ايراني ربما هناك
كثير من الاسباب اما ان تكون الاسباب خلاف
مع سوريا على بعض المسائل الحقيقه يعني
انا يؤكد لك الان ومستعد ان اظهر معك في
برنامج بعد سنه او يؤكد لك بان هذا الكلام
غير صحيح ههه
سؤال باختصار انت تقول ان العلاقه سويه مع
ايران هل دمشق قادره على احداث توازن في
العلاقات ما بين ما بين انفتاحها على
الدول العربيه وايضا على تركيا
يعني انا تعلمين بان ايران هي التي كانت
تطلب من دمشق القرب من تركيا ايران ال ال
ايران هي التي كانت تطلب من دمشق المصالحه
مع سوريا وسوريا هي التي كانت ترفض ثم
العلاقه ما بعض الدول العربيه سواء كما
سلطنه عمان بعلم ايران مع الكويت ما بعلم
ايران حتى مع الامارات يعني ايران حليف
لسوريا وتعلم بهذا الانفتاح مع الدول
العربيه وايران ليست ضد انفتاح سوري على
الدول العربيه بالعكس لايران مصلحه ان
تكون علاقه سوريا العربيه ان تكون علاقه
مميزه
الايرانيه
مع ايران وكل شيء يحدث بهذه المعرفه اذا
ما صح التعبير من قبل ايران ومباركتها اذا
ما صحت تعبير همم لماذا انتم من خلال
الاعلام تاخذون مثل هذه المعلومات
وتعتبرون ان العلاقه ليست سويه بين
البلدين بينما يقول السيد عمر انها على
عكس ذلك
يعني ايضا من ضمن الاسباب التي ادت الى
امتعاض السوري من النظام الايراني هو
استخدام هذه الحرب الاخرىنيه واستخدام
الانشغال الروسي وبالتالي ان يكونوا بديلا
للرموز داخل ايران الامر الذي يرفضها
النظام السوري بالنسبه لنظام السوري يعرف
تماما بان هذا النظام النظام ايديولوجي
اينما يوجد يغير تركيب الديموغرافيه يحاول
ان ان يتغلغل داخل هذه المنطقه عبر
الايديولوجيا الامر الذي لا تعمله كثيرا
همم روسيا يعني روسيا خلقت من الاشياء
نوعا ما في بعض المناطق لها ولكن ليست من
انشاء طائفيه كما هو همم
بالنسبه الايرانيين اما فيما يتعلق بانه
هل دمشق قادره على هذا التوازن خلق هذا
التوازن بين على علاقتها مع ايران
وعلاقتها مع الدول العربيه لا تصور ذلك
ومحور كما يقول النظام الايراني هو محور
يسمي محور المقاومه اما ان تكون فيه
والطرف الاخر هو المحور الاخر يصفه النظام
الايراني ويصفه الميليشيات
التابعه على انهم محور
تابع هذه الشعارات التي يتحدث عنها النظام
فبالتالي لا يمكنك ان ان ان ان ان ان ان
ان ان تكون يعني تجري هذه التوازن بين
العلاقات ولا يمكن لاي دوله اما ان تكون
مع هذا النظام بكل
منها كذلك سيد همم يعقوب هي مع هذا النظام
وراهانت عليه وستمرتها بالنهايه
نعم هو كذلك يعني هو نتصورها بانها يعني
لا هي ال ال ال النظام السوري اما ان يقرر
ان يتوجه عربيا وبالتالي يتخلى عن هذا
النظام ويواجه ويواجه النظامين هذا النظام
لن ينسحب بشكل عادي من المسؤوليه خلاهم
الاشياء الطائفيه داخل هذه المناطق
وتغلغل فيها في الحقيقه
الانسحاب ايران من سوريا وياتي عبر اخر
استخدام طلقه ممكن يستخدمها النظام
الايراني داخل سوريا اذا ارادوا ان على
عربيا عليهم ان يتخلوا من هذا النظام وان
يحارب وجود داخل سوريا ولكن غير ذلك لا
يمكن ان تحقيق توازن في العلاقه تعليق
اخير سيد عمر باختصار
العرب مع ايران في كل
الاجزاء في المنطقه في كل الاقليم في
اليمن في لبنان في الاردن في فلسطين لو
اختلف العرب مع ايران في كل المسائل لم
يختلفوا مع ايران في سوريا لان ايران وقفت
مع الدوله ومع بقاء الدوله عندما كان
العرب ضد سوريا الان هذا العرب الى الدوله
السوريه يعني ال- ال- هناك سوريا هي نقطه
التقاء عربيه ايرانيه وليست نقطه خلاف وما
كان سابقا في الايام السابقه الان اصبح
مساله اتفاق بالاخص في المساله السوريه
اما موضوع من انشاءات وهذا الكلام كله في
الحقيقه سوريا دوله وتتعامل مع ايران
كدوله وهناك اتفاقيات اقتصاديه وعسكريه
وكل ما يشاع بان منه شات وسيط
وثائق تظهر ذلك ولكن على كلن من دمشق كان
معنا عبر سكايب عمر رحمون المتحدث باسم
همم مصالحه السوريه شكرا لك ومن امستردام
عبر سكايب يعقوب سعيد الباحث في شان
الايراني شكرا جزيلا لك